Luke dominate here at the October's
YouTube channel and today we're in the
Highlands of Scotland and we're about to
do a survival camping trip we're gonna
build shelters we're gonna try to catch
your own dinner we're gonna forge food
this is gonna be awesome you guys ready
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
see this is this is a special net that
protects your heads from the bugs you
see these no seams are everywhere there
are gnats or whatever and so the boys
have got themselves hoods and I might
bust one out here to it a little bit but
so far I'm doing okay this class we're
doing is through Wildwood bushcraft calm
and Leon here is gonna be a our teacher
hissed this man has bitten off more than
he can chew he is gonna see if he can
survive a four-year-old in the
six-year-old there's all these big black
slugs here I thought they were deer poop
honestly oh yeah you got a you got a
whole fist full of slug just keep an eye
out in the water for a sea otter
big shoulder fish coming in today come
on guys keep going yeah it's just
absolutely gorgeous scenery look at this
this is such a cool forest so we know
that the rain doesn't get down here very
much because it's already dry even
though it's been raining all day so we
wouldn't have to build as much if we
built the shelter here could you guys
fit under there you think you fit you
totally fit under there there's this
little clover yeah it looks like clothes
but it isn't clear it's um is that she
called wood sorrel so it's quite sour
where you gonna sleep stuff here that's
pretty dry so Leon suggestion delay in
my shelter was really good because it
turned out right where I want to sleep
it's a big pointy Rock so I'm gonna see
if I could dig a little bit get that
rock out
ah there you go
that will make life better there we go
okay it's been raining like crazy so in
a futile effort to make it slightly
drier I'm trying to beat it off a little
bit of the droplets but well let's see
if that does any good whatsoever I'm
gonna jam up these holes with some logs
and bracken use all the small sticks to
fill up the holes like sleeping bag um I
wasn't going to but but these boys will
I got this these holes shoved up pretty
tight I think I'm ready to lay down my
Betty then we get a roof on this thing
gotta try to stick the stem side deep in
there so I'm more on the leaves and less
on the staff how many times a week do
you do these classes is it pretty
regular much space a week what do you
tell you
[Music]
I'm gonna jump in this pile of brush
here and see what it looks like inside
well there we go we use a lot of ferns
but man that looks pretty tight in there
it is pitch black inside and it's really
warm I get in there my big old fat body
is like a space heater in there that
despite the outside appearance there's
not a lot of space on the inside it's
packed pretty thick with insulation so
that should keep the rain off knock on
wood will have a pretty good good
night's rest in that so we got this
other shelter here made up for the boys
you can see it's got a little bit more
space in there and not bad at all you
can see what it looks like inside you
know pretty nice plenty of room for two
boys so there you go there's your
sleeping bag got it in there all right
we got the shelters built now we're
gonna go and try to get a fire going
cook a little food before we put the
boys to bed all right Tommy you got some
good you got some good kindling there
Tommy has been talking nonstop about fat
wood he saw on the old YouTube to make
some really fine little pieces on here
called a feather stick honey where do
you get your knife from so I make this
knife yeah they're kind of ready to go
so what I do and I'm lighting I rest my
hand on this I put a lot of pressure and
then I shoot sparks down yeah but then
you don't end up smashing your put into
the flame just gently let drop it Chuck
there you go
yeah look at that birds
[Music]
all right you want you want to shove
your Apple in that yeah just rest it on
that see yeah you know you can dip in
the hot chocolate digestives I got a
sneaky feeling it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
turn a little bit take that too hot good
cooks take roasted apples and digestives
that's a that's a pretty decent camping
meal I'm pretty happy with that but is
way past the boys bedtime so we're gonna
tuck them into their forts here a little
bit and then I'll see you guys in the
morning
all right guys you snuggled in good
are you warm are you dry good well the
boys fell asleep immediately and now
it's time for me to get to bed I'm gonna
crawl in here and I'm gonna bring the
light and show you a little bit what it
looks like inside I'm getting to bed all
right let's get inside here
all right all right all right welcome to
home sweet home let me show you the
master bedroom yep that's it
I am really really warm right now the
grounds a little cold
and if there's one thing that I could
improve I really need more of a layer
underneath me we're just gonna kind of
suck it up and I'll see you guys in the
morning I'll let you know how it was
well good morning at 6 a.m. and didn't
sleep half bad grounds a little hard but
it's warm in here unfortunately I didn't
quite make the shelter long enough my
feet are sticking out the door a little
bit when I stretch out like this and
it's pretty cold outside and my my toes
are cold and everyone so I get a little
bit of a cold breeze come in through the
door so if I had to do it over again I
think I would make a plug for the door
and make it a little bit longer a little
more padding wouldn't go amiss either
oh sure is a pretty spot isn't this
amazing
this is what I'm waking up to the most
amazing part about camping here in
Scotland is the loss anything that's
open land you can camp on it hike on it
build a fire on it doesn't matter
whether its private or not just clean up
after yourself use some common sense and
it's all fair game
if you're a backcountry enthusiast this
place is amazing
look at that there's a fish blitz going
on right down there and see just fish
just erupting out of the water out there
oh I think we're gonna do some fishing
today that's that's got my blood pumping
I'm gonna see if I can get some wood
together and get a little fire going so
the boys will have something warm to sit
by women to get up see if I can get some
dry wood shavings a little fire started
now we're gonna try to make some
breakfast here I heard something about
seaweed and flatbread so this is gonna
be interesting if I was actually made by
me I used to get some practice but I got
the cob on fire cool stuff buddy yeah
buddy
you want to eat a limpet this little
thing is a little bit we're gonna catch
a neat one so have to surprise all the
brown seaweeds of racks of some kind
sometimes known as gut weed that's
supposed to resemble intestines when
it's like you took quite seagrass as
well yes that's a edible periwinkle
appear you in the edible periwinkle your
old Winkle yeah you could eat it raw are
those bears more safe to cook it there
are big computers out just a shell
Gracie just bunking with the rock yeah
first thing you have to take the cut off
there you go a little bit of roll a bit
crunchy into it irony a little bit
nosebleed some people really like them
roar some people are not keen it wasn't
my favorite raw thing I put my mouth but
one bad definitely a little bit
nosebleed in it pick some the seaweed
really well cement you doing the
old-fashioned way dump it in put it in
there buddy all right throw a little
salt and pepper in it but that's good
there's your little seaweed cake I would
put it limpets Bannock that's that's my
ranking right now for things I've put in
my mouth this morning alright just
finished up breakfast so now we're gonna
do some fishing which I'm super excited
about and Leon's got some kind of
survival fishing gear and I'm cheating a
little bit and grab my dog wash surf rod
real quick and we're gonna go around the
coast here and see if we can't catch any
fish
yeah look there are fish in there mr.
rates looking here
I caught him mmm we're gonna try some
fish in here we saw some bait oh look
right there just poppin right there all
over the place so you can see all these
little baitfish dead and though the
seaweed here what happened is that high
tide they jumped out of the water to get
away from the pole Accor whatever's
eating them got this little pot here got
a little spinner on it it's like what we
do with the water bottles we're gonna
see if we can catch a Pollock or
something with this survival surf
fishing
[Applause]
took them long to where the pole is out
there yeah there we go
little public man there littles a little
fish and chip right there but you can't
stop oh why did you check him in the
water since he's still alive maybe he'll
attract more Pollock good job oh yeah
you just swam off all right Nate you
want to catch a fish put him in there
keep them fresh
[Applause]
oh he's big okay look at this huh staff
is so much fun but the rims getting
serious on us so we're gonna head back
to camp to get a little dry buddy are
you love munching that would sell Oh
chocolate caramel digestive in hot
chocolate man that's match made in
heaven time to cook up our haggis here
because we are in Scotland and so you
got to have campfire haggis agen you
want to try some some haggis no no this
just made with like sheep lungs and
sheep hearts and sheep stomachs it
actually smells quite nice it smells
like a sausage
all right this fish is looking pretty
done the eyes turned all white and
cloudy and he's got little grease coming
out of his nose do you wanna try some
haggis yeah I always call it like meaty
sausages granola it's kind of like this
crunchy texture it reminds me of warm
granola smells like sausage it tastes
like sausage
there's clothes you guys
what are you got there what are you
eating yo you're eating more haggis you
are turning into a Scotsman we finished
our haggis and public lunch and we're
gonna go explore a little cove down the
way and we're gonna cut through the
woods and do a little foraging and along
the way just uh just do a little
exploring
Sean Tyrell oh yeah chanterelle it's a
nice mushroom it's a good edible
mushroom and it's good sometimes but the
smell of fruit smell apricots kinda no
no they definitely doesn't smell like a
button mushroom say North you that's
clover okay like clover in wood sorrel
oh what's ur over the heart shaped leaf
heart shape see this is kind of fairly
round now this is mountain ash oh you
can eat it neutrons
it's about sour sort of tasting it's
called common sorrel common soil
yeah oh yeah yeah I'm getting that I'm
getting that rhubarb case it's in the
was a brittle cap family so they're like
brittle and they kind of they often you
know a little of like teeth sticking out
of here but some of the ones with the
red tops like this are circles sickness
so they make you feel sick the ones that
are sick iners all have a kind of hot
fiery taste called skullcap look out
skullcap and reasonable skullcap is
because it's a sleep-inducing oh oh
there you go
there's always water in Nathan's boots
Latos limpet you're not tough Olympus
you need this guy oh here we go
oh come here Nate mom's gonna see this
video and be like you guys are eating
haggis we're all limpets and you won't
eat what I make for you this is you're
gonna have some explaining to do you
ready to eat your limpet eat it like
that good
beyond the tidal pool Oh make sure you
put them all back buddy we're not gonna
eat those look at this view isn't this
awesome this Coast is just beautiful
yeah bog myrtle or Gale yeah great
pleasant aroma to it
ninja roll well guys we taught you how
to survive on your own see you later
[Applause]
tri step on the rocks and logs red deer
right there
that was Leon ago well guys we have had
an absolute blast on this camping trip
haven't we guys now listen if you would
like to do a trip like this contact
Lynne Durban with Wildwood bushcraft
calm I'll put a link in the description
also if you guys want to see more video
from our three-week trip to the UK check
out those videos I'll put a link in the
description to that as well but anyway
thanks for watching we hope you guys had
a great time if you want to see more
videos like this don't forget to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys YouTube
channel we put out new videos every
Saturday morning thanks for watching
guys if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
issues thanks for watching
[Music]